on va démarrer avec des images
absolument aberrante et je sais que vous
allez certainement réagir sont des
images d'une passagère d'un avion qui a
été expulsé d'un vol après avoir humilié
des passagers en surpoids un gardé à
l'aéroport de las vegas cette femme
blonde dit au téléphone
mon dieu je ne sais pas comment je vais
faire pour tenir encore quatre heures
comme ça ils sont si gros qu'il me
compresse elle parle de ses voisins sa
voisine qui filme appelle alors une
hôtesse vous pouvez vous trouver une
autre place à 7
la blonde explique je ne peux même pas
m'asseoir parce qu'ils sont tous les
deux trop gros dit elle je ne peux pas
bouger
le test l'a fait alors se lever et en
croisant son imposant voisin
la femme dit moi je mange de la salade
derrière d'autres passagers s'indigne
vous devriez avoir honte du style allez
vous asseoir là-bas entre ces deux gros
cochon dit la femme une femme qui sera
finalement expulsé de l'avion où tous
les sièges sont pris une femme peu
délicate pour un problème plus délicat
aux états unis où plus d'un tiers des
adultes sont obèses alors en france 20%
des personnes obèses au chômage estime
avoir été discriminée qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette scène comme moi je
trouve absolument surréaliste on va
commencer par vous jimmy écouter alors
il est évident que l'humiliation est
inutile les remarques qu'elle a pu faire
auprès de ces personnes appelées en se
filmant tout ça c'est lamentable
elle aurait pu avoir l'élégance au
minimum de dire elle peut être gêné on
peut comprendre que si elle a plus de
place et on peut comprendre que si elle
n'a plus de place et qu'elle est serré
car les compagnies cherchent à faire que
de l'optimisation de petites séries
qu'on soit à côté d'une personne en ceci
elle était rangée demandé à l'hôtesse
est ce qu'il ya une place de disponible
par hasard c'est oui ou c'est non si
c'est oui
est-ce que je peux y aller très bien si
c'est non ben je reste à ma place
l'expulser très bien mais le jour où moi
il m'est arrivé quelque chose dans un
avion où j'ai eu quelqu'un à côté de moi
qui se tripotaient je vous assure c'est
une vraie histoire
j'ai signalé à l'hôtesse et s'est rien
passé on la laissait donc n'a pas
pardonné est en train de comparer keith
harris tripote et qui est ton gun un
petit absolument y observer aux rien
fait à l'essai dans l'avion sur toi ça
n'a absolument rien alors non non non je
compare pas les choses dans le sens où
la personne qui se tripoter à côté de
moi n'a pas été expulsé de l'avion donc
j'aimerais une même police pour tout le
monde et cette dame là bien sûr que elle
elle n'avait pas à tenir ces propos mais
elle pouvait simple elle a l'info fait
mais tu plais beaucoup à l'étranger
n'est qu'elle peut qu'elle puisse jamais
demandé beaucoup sur un vol long
courrier de changer de place
caroline alors pour être très honnête je
franchement je comprends qu'elles
puissent sentir une gêne de se sentir
une quand ils ont un avion on est en
plein dans la vie on n'est pas tant mais
c'est la loterie enfin ça s'appelle
quand on voyage en classe éco comme ça
parce qu est le cas d'ailleurs de la
majorité des gens et moi comprise c'est
la loterie on appelle ça la médaille s
est pas pour rien on peut tomber sur un
voisin un peu en surpoids on peut tomber
sur un voisin qui pue de la gueule
on peut tourner sur un beau gosse on
peut tomber sur un beau gosse et bin
houin enfants mais c'est la loterie
donc il se trouve que là mais
l'impression pardonnez moi parce que
savoure le prendre mais c'est la vie
avion c'est la vie ben oui quand vous
vous excusez insociable en disant bas où
il a été gêné moi je suis
particulièrement choquée je le dis
pardon à mes cette femme est une abrutie
ayant large de musique mais mam et leurs
tenues sont pourtant est inadmissible et
en plus très politiquement incorrect
mais il faut aussi se dire que la nana
elle a payé son billet peut-être que le
sua comment donc elle a le droit de dire
que si ici s'il ya des gens qui déborde
sur son siège et qu' il ne reste plus
que la moitié de son siège est là elle a
quand même raison de dire qu'elle est
gêné maintenant c'est son comportement
et la manière de faire qui est
totalement inadmissible amène en effet
le jeu quand on voyage comme ça c'est la
loterie moi je comprends complètement
son agacement dans la mesure où je
comprends maintenant attendez je ne
cautionne pas du tout l'humiliation de
cette femme qui effectivement s'adresse
à ces personnes en surpoids de façon
absolument aberrante néanmoins je
comprends son agacement pourquoi parce
que les places dans les avions sont
scandaleusement trop étroite entre 43 et
45 cm de largeur comment voulez vous que
des personnes nommées danse urbaine et
moi mais que y ait quelques âmes en
surpoids à côté de vous pas le taux de
votre siège est toujours le même il faut
donc vous êtes quoi qu'il arrive de
conservation serré que vous avez
quelqu'un qui soit fort ou pas à côté de
vous il faudrait faire comme cette
compagnie aérienne qui en 2016 à placer
des personnes en fonction de leur poids
dans l'avion pour tous chacun non mais
attendez généré ça il ya une compagnie
aérienne qui à répartir entre guillemets
exactement les personnes de façon à ce
qu'elle soit confortablement installés
çà vaut aussi bien pour les personnes
entre guillemets mince manif vous l'avez
oui c'est la huayra lines c'était en
moyenne airlines exactement et qui a
fait ça alors évidemment il ya une
plainte qui a été déposée ça fait cinq
ans qu'elle allait enfin ça peut se
comprendre
cette parité par ce nom ça me choque pas
parce que c'est bien pour tout le monde
pour les personnes un peu fortes comme
les personnes qui sont beaucoup plus
fine parce que la personne qui est forte
qui se retrouvaient quelqu'un juste à
côté c'est aussi inconfortable au
pourrait le nommer
vous avez menti sur place et c'est vous
qui déplacer le problème
mais non mais non mais parce
qu'aujourd'hui dès qu'on aborde le sujet
du surpoids de quelqu'un un des gros
sauts france on est grosso phone et on
n'a pas droit de 10 mais là en
l'occurrence à l'éclairement gros sous
elle aurait dû la même chose à quelqu'un
par exemple qui pue lie hainard mais ici
on aurait dû car oui c'est normal
mosca rôle éminent et les mois mais là
en l'occurrence vous quelqu'un qui s'en
tire est mauvais parce que ils se
seraient pas laver les dents tout
bêtement parce qu'il sentirait l'ail
l'oignon ce que vous voulez c'est entre
guillemets de sa faute
être en surpoids s'est uni de sa faute
n'est pas de sa faute c'est juste un
état de faits non mais elle elle pense
que elle elle est très égoïste elle
pense que là elle et à son petit elle
elle est mignonne malgache et devant
dieu prend l'avion est belle pour une
place en première alors à tout l'argent
alors si je le ferai non mon chat je
suis désolé je voyage toujours en classe
éco je suis un peu plus forte que toi
donc oui mais je ne suis pas au ps mais
c'est bien gentil toi de ta pâte est
comme ça devenir d'irwin un machin les
les gros il faut qu'il fasse attention à
ce qu'ils soient à chacun de l'avion et
tout ça on a exactement je leur ai dit
tout à l'heure je la paye doit la série
des compagnies assez sûr que son
comportement est inadmissible et c'est
très bien que la compagnie qu'il soit
allé jusqu à l'expulser parce qu'elle
n'a pas à avoir ce comportement est à
être médisantes comme ça elle aurait dû
s'occuper juste de son petit qu'à
essayer de sauver sa peau tous les
sujets d'accords montre qu'il ait essayé
de trouver une autre place dans laquelle
elle serait un petit ex elle aurait un
peu moins l'impression d'être d'être
d'être compressé entre guillemets mais
c'est très bien que la compagnie ait
réagi comme ça et c'est très bien que
les gens et moi dans l'avion aurait été
la première aussi à dire non mais ça va
pas bien de parler comme ça mais faut se
dire aussi que c'est pas parce qu'on
aborde ce sujet que systématiquement on
doit on doit pas dire je compte un peu
ce qu'on pense aussi l'accord met enfin
en deux de là à insulter les personnes
et atlas et l'arrivée de façon unanime
le hashtag ccq dlt n'hésitez pas à
réagir sur cette vidéo qui est quand
même enfin sur les images moi je le
trouve assez aberrante